pixel doesn't make mistakes drama
follows up on this Theory by doing a
deep investigation of his own into
Hoffman which is the inspiration behind
one of my favorite letterbox reviews
this movie is about a detective figuring
out the plots of Saw 3 and saw 4. in the
meantime Hoffman cuts the ribbon on the
next major game the trial of the Fatal
Five these subjects were all involved in
allowing a building fire to occur years
ago and to be covered up which furthered
their own careers at the expense of
others their tests were created for them
to work together in order to survive as
this is going on Hoffman makes contact
with special agent strom's Superior
special agent Ericsson or as I like to
call him Jay Jonah Erickson
[Laughter]
he starts to plant the seeds in
Erickson's head of Strom possibly being
jigsaw's other accomplice he sets things
up at the location where the Fatal 5
game is being held to make it look like
Strom was behind it all they're crap
crap crap Mega crap